where's the source of meaning
when you're not the center of the
universe when the you doesn't even exist
that even you the the the sense of self
and this and the sense of decision
making is an illusion
the truth is that for the most part the
sense of self is kind of at the core of
human suffering because it feels as if
we are separate from the rest of nature
we're separate from each other we're
separate from
um you know the the illusion that I that
I referenced a feeling like you know we
have these thoughts that are brain-based
thoughts but then the eye swoops in to
make a decision
um in some sense it goes so deep that
it's as if the eye is separate from the
physical world
and that separation
um plays a part in depression plays a
part in anxiety even plays a part in
addiction so at the level of the brain I
think stop me if I'm repeating myself
but we started talking about the default
mode Network
um and so we actually know that when the
default mode network is quieted down
when people lose a sense of self in
meditation and on psychedelic drugs in
in therapy
there is a feeling that people describe
of
an extremely positive feeling of being
connected to the rest of Nature and so
that's a piece of it that I think if you
haven't had the experience
um you wouldn't necessarily know that
would be a part of it
but truly having that Insight that
you're not the self you feel you are
immediately your experiences are
embedded in the universe and you are a
piece of everything and you see that
everything is interconnected and so
rather than feeling like a lonely eye in
this bigger Universe there's a sense of
being a part of something larger than
yourself and this is intrinsically
positive for human beings
um and even just in our everyday lives
and choices and what we do for work
feeling part of something larger than
yourself is the way people describe
spiritual experiences in the way
um many positive psychological states
are framed and so there there's that
piece of it there's something there's a
one giant hug with the universe uh
everything in it but there is some sense
in which
we attach the search for meaning
with um the eye
with the ego
and uh you you it could almost seem like
life is meaningless our existence our
eye my existence is meaningless it
doesn't kind of go there under any world
view right really right
um and the truth is
we want to find
a truth
out of that downward spiral and not
a story that
we have to tell ourselves that isn't
true and the fact is we have these facts
available to us that
in with the right Framing and the right
context
um
looking at the truth actually provides
us with that psychological feeling we're
searching for and I think that's
important to point out I think humans
are
fascinatingly good at finding Beauty In
Truth No matter how painful the truth is
so yes I totally agree yes but in this
case
I think there are
the concerns are legitimate concerns and
I have them myself for how people
respond I've actually had people tell me
they had to stop reading my book halfway
through
because
the parts on Free Will were so upsetting
to them
and this is something I think about a
lot because of that
kind of breaks my heart
um I don't
because I see this potential
for these realizations bringing
levels of well-being that many people
don't have access to
um I think it's important to talk about
them in ways that override what can be
an initial
um
fear or kind of spooky spooky quality
that can come out of these realizations